نحن بداخل طائره ايرباص 319 التابعه
للقوات الجويه الباكستانيه وهي بالفعل هي
طائره مدنيه
وتحمل على متنها 140 شخص من رعايه باكستان
الذين تم اجلاؤهم من السودان عبر سفن
السعوديه طبعا هؤلاء الذين الان يغادرون
الى من قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه في
مدينه جده الى مدينه كراتشي تحديدا وهم تم
انهاء اجراءاتهم بعد ان تم ايضا تسهيل
ومنحهم التاشيره او تاشيره الدخول التي
تمكنهم من الدخول من الاراضي السعوديه حتى
خروجهم ومغادرتهم الى بلدانهم طبعا هناك
كنم ايضا بحضور القنصل العام الباكستاني
وكذلك عدد من القيادات الموجوده في قاعده
الملك عبد الجويه وايضا هنا عدد من
الرعايه الذين يقومون
[موسيقى]
عدد من الرعايه الذين الان تم انهاء
اجراءاتهم فقط في انتهاء
المراحل الاخيره من التشييك النهائي على
هذه الطائره وبعد ذلك سوف يغادرون طبعا
هذه الرحله هي تعتبر الرحله رقم تسعه
واربعين التي تنفذ في قاعده الملك او
قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه وهي من ضمن
الرحلات الجويه التي تقوم باشراف عليها
القوات الجويه الملكيه السعوديه هناك
طائرات عسكريه اجنبيه وكذلك تجاريه اضافه
الى طائرات عسكريه ايضا تابعه للقوات
الجويه الملكيه السعوديه قامت باجلاع
الكثير والعديد من الرعايه من جنسيات
مختلفه لن ننسى ايضا هناك في الجهه الاخرى
الموانع وكذلك الاسطول البحري مستمر ولم
يتوقف هناك ايضا اليوم كانت وصلت الى
قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه رحلتين
قادمتين من بورسودان وتم اجلاؤهم والانئهم
يقومون بانهاء اجراءاتهم الاولى كانت
طائره باكستانيه عسكريه من الهند والاخرى
كانت ايضا عسكريه من نوع
باكستانيه وايضا يتوقع ان تصل ايضا خلال
الساعات القادمه طائره اخرى لكن سوف يتم
التعرف عليها بشكل اوضح وايسر وافضل ربما
هذه الازمه في السودان جعلتنا نكتشف ان
هناك العديد يعني اعداد كبيره من الرعايه
الاجانب يعملون هناك في السودان صحيح يعني
من خلال اعداد الرحلات الكبيره كما ذكرت
49 رحله حتى الان فقط من قاعده الملك عبد
الله الجويه
ما طبيعه النشاطات او الاعمال التي كان
كانت تقوم بها هذه الجاليه مثلا الجاليه
او هذه الرحله من
رعايه الباكستانيين ما طبيعه الاعمال التي
كانوا يقومون بها في السودان
[تصفيق]
هؤلاء الرعايه سواء من تحديده من الجنسيات
الاسيويه كانت هناك شركات تابعه او كانت
تعمل مع الحكومه
في السودان سواء في مصانع الرخام او كذلك
مصانع الاسفنج وبعضهم ايضا في مصانع انتاج
الطلاء فالمعظم كان يتحدث هناك ايضا الجزء
الاخر كان يعمل في مشاريع مقاولات وكنت
اتحدث معهم هل لماذا اختاروا السودان
تختار الجنسيه الاسيويه تحديدا لماذا لم
يكن هناك ايضا بالنسبه لايدي العامله في
السودان وهم كثر
فالاجابه كانت بحسب يعني صاحب خبره من احد
الرعايه الموجودين قال ان تكلفه العيد
العامله بالنسبه او الاجر لدى العامل في
اسيا ارخص بكثير من اجره
اليوميه بالنسبه
للمواطنين في السودان فلذلك كان هناك عدد
رعايه طبعا هؤلاء عدد
بسيط هناك الالاف بحسب كحديثهم وكلامهم
ايضا بالنسبه رعايه باكستان تحديدا تبقى
قرابه الالف شخص او الف ايضا ممن سوف يتم
اجناؤهم خلال اليومين او ثلاثه ايام
القادمه اما عبر السفن السعوديه او تبع
القوات البحريه الملكيه السعوديه او كذلك
عبر طائرات عسكريه باكستانيه صحيح
وبالتالي يعني هذه الحرب يهاني قطعت
بارزاق هؤلاء الالاف من العمال الاسيويين
الذين يعني كان السودان مصدر رزقهم كما
ذكرت يعني في ان كان في معامل الرخام او
في اعمال المقاولات والبناء في السودان هم
يعودون الان الى اراضيهم يعني او الى
بلادهم كما تبعنا مع علامات طائره تجري
رعايه الى دوله باكستان وقبل قليل
زميلنا السلمي كذلك كان مع طائره اخرى
تجلي رعايه باتجاه الهند مهاني نحن الان
في الاسبوع ندخل الاسبوع عن ثالثا من
المواجهات العسكريه في السودان هل من
معلومات الى متى ستستمر عمليات اجلاء
الرعايه الاجانب عبر السعوديه
طبعا لا يوجد موعد محدد دقيق ولكن في
الحقيقه ما نشاهده نعم محدد ولكن ما
نشاهده من خلال الاستمرار واستمرار عمليات
الاجلاء سواء في الجسر الجوي او كذلك في
الاسطول البحري واضح جدا ان هناك مازال
المزيد لا ننسى ايضا صهيب هناك ايضا مساله
اخرى هناك بعض الرعايه من جنسيات عربيه لا
يوجد لديها قنصليات او سفارات وكذلك لم لا
تستطيع الخروج من السودان بسبب ايضا حملها
لبعض الوثائق او لا يوجد ايضا لديهم
قنصليه يتواصلون معها عموما اليوم ممكن ان
نتحدث مع
مدير عام الجوازات في السعوديه الفريق
سليمان اليحيى والذي تحدث للعربيه ان
هؤلاء الرعايه الذين ياتون يمنح لهم
تاشيره دخول طارئه بالمجان وايضا يتمكنهم
المغادره ايضا هناك بعض او معظم الاشخاص
لا يحملون
جوازات او وثائق فيتم لاستخراج لهم تصاريح
وجوازات بعد التنسيق مع سفرات ام من
القنصرياتهم حتى يتمكنوننا من الخروج
والمغادره بسلام شكرا جزيلا لك هاني صفيان
مباشره من قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه في
جده
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات